like fireflies on a still summer night
they gently dot and illuminate the
infinite Velveteen sky stars be they
millions or billions of years old are
all born in nebulae clouds of dust and
mostly hydrogen gas within these stellar
nurseries stars begin life as protostars
or hot cores formed by the collection
and collapse of dust and gas at the
protostars become hotter hydrogen nuclei
inside of the cores begin to fuse and
create helium it is this chemical
reaction thermonuclear fusion that
generates a star's heat and energy and
causes it to shine stars are categorized
by a number of characteristics one of
these classifications is by surface
temperature called spectral classes
these seven major groups range from the
coolest stars which are designated as M
and up to the hottest stars which are
designated as o stars are also
classified by the amount of light they
emit or luminosity called luminosity
classes these nine major groups range
from the small less bright white dwarves
to the large and extremely bright
hypergiants
but no matter their luminosity or
surface temperature all stars eventually
burned through their hydrogen fuel and
died out less massive stars such as our
Sun release their stellar material into
space leaving behind a white dwarf
surrounded by a planetary nebula more
massive stars instead blast matter into
space and a bright supernova leaving
behind an extremely dense body called a
neutron star with the most massive stars
stars that are at least three times our
sun's mass collapse into themselves and
create a bottomless well of gravity a
black hole but from the remnants of
stars heavier elements are cast into the
universe and it is this star dust that
formed the seedlings of life itself
[Music]